(rooster crowing)
(music plays)
- I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going
I wake up every morning
(typing sounds)
- My name is Alex Parish,
protecting our country
had always been my dream.
I went to go as my first audition
I knew I had to go in
to this room and read
these lines in front of all these people
but I was so nervous before I went in,
so I went to the bathroom I remember,
before I went in and I
looked in the mirror,
and this is so stupid and cliche,
but I talked to myself and I said,
"What's wrong with you?
You've played the most
difficult characters
in the most complicated movies
I tossed my hair a little bit,
felt great and walked out.
Did my bit and got the job.
(laughing)
(music plays)
- I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going.